i know your real life story it's a very
difficult story there is so many
parallels in this show to your real life
this thing about pulling out your hair
yeah trichotillomania you're so open and
honest but yet you were embarrassed that
you had this when i was 13 i pulled out
so much hair that i needed to get a wig
and wear it we were awake to school and
it was it was humiliating and it was
um
it was really hard is it humiliating
because you know you should stop doing
it it was like just feeling like you're
deformed
you know like feeling feeling ugly and
unlovable and
um and and
having big bald spots i mean
it was like getting ready for school
every day you know i ate my lunch in the
nurse's office because
because people like were
like i heard someone say like that i
made them sick
wow so kids were making fun of you at
school yeah and i was extra confident i
always had a boyfriend i was always like
everybody cool has no hair you know like
i
i was just
i was just
i thought i was okay like i i thought i
was okay and i didn't realize that i was
not okay and that the hair pulling was a
symptom of that i would not even realize
i did it and just look down and there'd
be a pile of hair were you so invisible
to your parents that they didn't really
address the situation they did they were
no it was my mom was especially like
just horrified and upset by it i
she would help me do my hair before
school every morning and she would be
crying while she helped me with my hair
oh my god this is like a major thing
that you've got you're going to see i'm
getting choked up i'm getting i'm
getting emotional
because i think you're getting emotional
because you had to keep it a secret for
so long yeah i i i didn't it's been like
a big it's been my big secret you know i
have so much shame about it and i just i
really just wanted to try to let go of
it and accept it about myself and um
yeah and this was this was part of that
how did you stop it though i still pull
my hair
oh you do i do i still do it if i if i
didn't have these voel extensions um i
would be
i couldn't be on camera i i have
probably half the amount of hair i
should have
wow and that's all from the point and
i'm lucky that um extensions have become
so normalized and every woman you see on
camera in any movie is wearing
a wig or has
a lot of added hair that's just how it
works in the business it's not even
strange like i used to be embarrassed
about having like these little clip-in
extensions
but i just think all these things that
we've you know been like ashamed of and
hiding or you know
women who you know we
put on makeup we put in extensions we
put you know but on spanx like it's it's
all
it's all good it's like just doing
whatever you want to do to feel good
the new show is fantastic you know what
i want to announce here which is
exciting is that um
hulu and endeavor content
have picked up life and bath for a
second season oh excellent i'm happy to
hear that when'd you get the news
honestly i just got a text right now
look at you texting and talking at the
same time
that's business yes i i really wanted i
really wanted to share that news on here
you know i mean what's bigger yeah
you